I was meeting him at a chingon spot and
I sat down I was out of breath he's like
you good he's like I yeah man I've been
you know I've been working he's like
congrats on quiz lady and I was like oh
man it's just a small part you know how
it is and he was like what do you mean
you know how it
is because I said I I wasn't thinking
and I was like a a small part man small
part you know how you shouldn't have
said it dude because now I swear to god
dude I'm not doing it oh my God I'm
sorry that's not what I meant what I
meant is like my small parts I'm not I'm
a seed stealer I wasn't refer I wasn't
referring to you having small parts and
you knowing how it is to have small
parts I was just my dick's small what
why did you reveal that he's saying I'm
you I'm having I have small parts